something happened this past weekend in
texas i don't know if you saw this story
drag your kids to pride was an event
that happened in
dallas
and essentially it was an event where
children went to what looked like a
nightclub and they
it was a drag club and they would dance
with the drag queens they would perform
with the drag queens they would give
money to the drag queens the drag queens
would perform for them the kids were
there with their parents and or
guardians kids played musical chairs in
front of the drag queens kind of we have
some of the images of the dancing
that we can just show for people who
missed it
so that's the kids playing musical
chairs you see their parents in the
background
um can we show the signs as well um
right here these are the signs that were
on the wall it's not going to lick
itself
and i licked it so it's mine now i ask
you you're your parent out there
you walk into that place you see those
signs you don't walk right out
even if you were well intentioned going
in maybe you thought it would just be a
fun event i don't know why that would be
in your mind because children don't
belong in a drag show
they just don't we'll talk about why in
a minute if you need that clarification
although most sane people don't but even
if you you thought oh it's going to be a
fun innocent event you walk in you see
those signs
i mean
people were dropping low splits very
provocative dancing um in front of very
very small children i mean those are
kids
so we have several problems um that are
going on this is this is the sign a of a
society in decay not the drag shows but
the fact that you have drag shows for
kids
one what's going on with parenting
why are parents i mean take the drag
component out of it for a second take
that out completely pretend this is just
a regular nightclub why are you why are
kids there do you take your cliff kids
around at night you're like hey kids
want to go to the cigar bar
hey kids want to go to the club at night
hey you want to go for a happy hour we
can all you know pop some shots this is
not normal this is not healthy
this is not i mean kids don't need to be
around alcohol and club scenes and
provocative dancing and sexualization
this is not healthy or normal now my
concern is
did the
a okay
did those parents want to take their
kids there if so i need to talk to them
why
b are these parents feeling pressured to
take kids to places like this so that
they can say well i'm i'm on the cool
team i support it see i'm i'm good i
support it you don't have to come after
me i support what's going on don't worry
i'm condoning it i'm supporting it see i
have my kids is there a push for
everyone to kind of support endorse
this stuff so much so that now children
are involved
this is deeply deeply deeply deeply
concerning and it's not i was told you
know when i brought this story to the
surface people were saying oh this is
happening in new york there's taxpayer
dollars already being put out there for
drag queens to come to schools and they
do makeup lessons for kids what
what is taxpayer funded what is going on
what was surprising to me is that it did
happen in texas so that's my point is
like this is
trickling everywhere
okay
now i said take the drag component out
of it for a second
let's take that component and bring it
back in now
i say this i grew up in new york city
right
i'm a live and let live kind of gal for
adult i'm like you do you you know i
have friends gay straight all stars and
stripes i've been to i went to a drag
club myself i think for a bachelorette
party i think i was like 22. um there's
a place called lucky changs i don't know
if it's still there it's in new york
city it's very famous can be very
entertaining
i would not bring my child there that's
not appropriate
um but there was a time when people
just wanted to be accepted you know i
remember a time when um a friend of mine
actually came out as gay to me in
college and i said we had a conversation
i remember her saying i just want to be
accepted for who i am i just want to be
left alone i don't want to be
discriminated against and i want to live
my life and i was like awesome that's
how it should be people should adults
should as long as you're not hurting
anyone else as long as you're not asking
someone else to pay for anything as long
as you're not asking someone else to
endorse what you're doing you should be
able to live the life you want to live
in a free society great that's not
what's happening now what's happening
now is there are a lot of woke causes
and they they don't just want you to
accept that you have to you have to
endorse it you have to say i support
this you have to put on a pin let's
pretend this is a pen it says [ __ ]
but you have to put on a pin and say
this i support what you're doing
i'm a fan i'm i've got you
why
why
i do plenty of things in my life i don't
need someone else to endorse or support
why why are we at that point now
and it's so much so that they need the
children to support it they need little
kids you cannot tell me you cannot tell
me that those little kids were
comfortable in that room they don't know
what's going on they're like i want to
go outside and play what am i doing here
in a room what what is this
they don't want to see a kids do not
want to go see a drag show i'm sorry but
they don't adults wanted them to go see
that show for some reason one reason or
another
and it's pervasive i mean you see tyra
banks now has that
show out
i'm looking for i think it's on
discovery plus i want to be accurate but
i think it's on discovery plus can you
just check that it's a show about
teenage
teens doing drag
um
looking it up right now yeah i believe
it's discovery plus discovery plus yeah
tyra banks executive producer
of teen drag series for discovery plus
right so
this is real
this is happening
this is
pervasive why why do they need it's like
in other words this needs to be
not only you don't they don't need you
to say you do you they need you to say
that's amazing i love what you're doing
i support it i don't just condone it in
fact i'm gonna make a sign for it and
put it on my lawn
that's where we're out in 2022.
no one should have to do that
no one should have to do that for anyone
else's cause i'm sorry and leave the
kids out of it leave them out of it let
them grow up if they decide as an adult
they want to go to a drag show they can
do what they want stop
putting woke political nonsense
onto kids stop putting kids in places
and saying see
this is cool you like this if you go to
school just say you like this so you'll
be in the cool club and no one will
criticize you and you won't be
no
raise your kids to think for themselves
and get them out of spaces where they
don't belong they don't belong in the
bar
they don't belong in a club and they
don't belong in the drag club if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]